i know you're hard at work at pinocchio
um and obviously i cannot wait to see it
uh for fans of yours uh what would you
like to tease them about the project
what do you want them to know about
pinocchio well it look it's it's a very
it's a very very very very personal
movie for me
the two the flip sides for me i've
always been pinocchio and frankenstein
of the same story because essentially
that's the same story you know
uh and and and the idea of
uh a pinocchio and that
talks about uh
things that i consider very deep but it
is fun and it's a musical at the same
time but i find it really really
incredibly moving obviously in animation
you get to see the movie
in storyboards beginning to end
many many times and then you add the
stop motion
and right now we are about
50 percent animated and 50 in
storyboards and every time i watch the
movie
i just saw
like like a baby
you know it's it's
as personal as it gets
as moving as it gets
and it's not uh
it's not it's unlike any other version
of the story that you've ever seen it's
completely unlike it and and and and
it's a bird it subverts the
the
moral underpinnings of the original
fable
which which is in order to be a real boy
you gotta change
and you gotta become flesh and blood and
you gotta become this is about
becoming a real boy by
by
acting on a real human i would say by
acting like a real human period
do you do you think it'll be out uh like
a year from now or oh yeah no the movie
will come out last quarter of 2022 so is
is curious because it's been almost five
years
since shape of water and now uh
it's gonna be two movies in a row one
after the other
i [ __ ] love it i'm just just being
honest